when you walk in an IMAX theater you
feel like you're coming into some kind
of Cathedral dedicated to the worship of
high-quality filmmaking
I definitely remember Terminator 2 it
was such a big deal the first one was
this small thing that kind of came out
of nowhere and then the second one was
an event why do you care what happens to
her because I was her Terminator movies
are supposed to be this combination of
character and action I don't think that
you get that big scope in any other way
as clearly and is overwhelmingly as you
do in an IMAX theater this is all over I
am going to kill you
I understand it is huge the action is
huge this is epic this goes on and on
and we sort of wrote this really amazing
action piece because Jim you know
casually throws down these gauntlets
like I need you to make the most
impressive plane crash action scene ever
put on film and that's that's what you
get and I think the best way to see that
is is in IMAX where you get fully
immersed in the experience in a way that
you can't in any other cinematic than
you
I can see a very upset I think this
movie will play an IMAX like mother